i'm going to talk about where the
chemical elements come from if you want
something close to a symbol i'm going to
talk about the r process and the s
process we're going to talk about
chemical elements which means i need to
venture alarmingly close to chemistry
and actually talk a little bit about the
periodic table so first let me show you
an astronomer's periodic table which is
this
there are only three things in the
universe as far as astronomers are
concerned there's hydrogen helium and
everything else which we tend to call
metals and the fraction of each
we tend to call x y and z i'm only
showing this because it really annoys
chemists but actually to a large extent
it's sort of helpful because actually
one of the things that astronomers
broadly know is that hydrogen and helium
were mainly made in the big bang and
everything else was more or less made in
stars if you do it by mass it's about
three quarters hydrogen one quarter
helium and a tiny bit of everything else
so a few percent of everything else so
these are not to scale in that sense all
right but it turns out astronomers do
know actually know a bit more about
chemical elements and where they come
from from that and in fact there's a
very nice graphic that appeared a little
while ago that tries to summarize it
it's caused quite a lot of discussion
and debate in the astronomical community
but at least to a first approximation it
kind of tells you what's going on and it
sort of reflects the story that i've
just told you that hydrogen and helium
were made in the big bang and pretty
much everything else was made in stars
now it turns out of course that's not
true when you start looking in detail at
things so for example when you start
looking at all the very heavy elements
which have very short lifetimes the only
way we can actually make those is by
making them ourselves because anything
was made in stars as long since decayed
away so the very heavy elements are
actually human-made rather than
star-made and actually it turns out when
you look at the light end of things
things are a little more complicated as
well because you've got things like
lithium and beryllium you see you've got
little seas next to them here they're
actually made through a process called
cosmic ray spallation cosmic rays are
these very high energy particles
whizzing through space and when on a
very high energy particle it could be an
atomic nucleus wax into another
particle could be another atomic nucleus
that you can actually have fission
occurring the atomic nuclei can fall
apart so something which was initially a
heavier element can actually be
splattered into these little bits we
believe the main way that lithium and
beryllium and boron get made is through
that spellation process so they weren't
actually made in stars well at least
something heavy was probably made in a
star but then it got smashed to pieces
through cosmic ray interactions the
broad story is that hydrogen and helium
made in the big bang then you have stars
stars in their center fuse lighter
elements to heavier elements because
that's how they're powered they're
fusion powered and so you can make
heavier elements one of the main ways
you make heavy elements is in the core
of a star when you've got hydrogen
turning into helium and helium turning
into carbon and so on but that kind of
gives out an iron because once you get
to iron then making heavier things by
smashing iron nuclei together it turns
out that absorbs energy rather than
giving energy out so you stop getting
energy out of the process when you get
to iron and of course if you're trying
to power a star you need to get energy
out so stars give up once they get to
iron and so again the simple law in in
astronomy is hydrogen and helium came in
the big bang everything up to iron was
made in the centers of stars and then
everything heavier than iron only gets
made in supernovae because when a star
explodes then you have lots of energy
around and you can have these very
inefficient processes you're not trying
to power a star anymore so actually you
can smack things together and create the
heavier elements like gold and all the
heavier things that are around get made
in supernovae
and if you look at this plot that's kind
of true
in that if you just look at it so we've
got the green and the yellow and stuff
that's made in stars and you can see all
the lighter elements as we go down the
periodic table tend to be green in
nature till we get to about iron
and then they sort of start turning more
to this pinky orange color which is
supernovae and so you can see the more
massive elements tend to get made in
in supernovae but interestingly it's not
entirely true it's not like everything
stops at iron and then suddenly
everything's made in supernovae and in
particular if you look at these guys
here so now i'm gonna have to struggle
with my command of the periodic table
and chemistry in general that's barium
lanthanum and cerium you can see they're
actually made in stars but they're way
heavier than i am right i am somewhere
away up here and these are right down
towards the bottom of the periodic table
and so the question is how on earth do
you end up with these heavy elements
which clearly aren't made in supernovae
but are actually are made in star
somewhere along the line and that's
where we get to this thing called the r
process and the s process it's actually
quite hard to make a heavy element
because you have to take so if you're
going to make a heavy element through
fusion you've got to take two fairly
heavy nuclei and smack them together and
get them to stick
and heavy nuclei have quite large
charges associated with them so you know
hydrogen only has one unit one proton
but by the time you get to these heavier
elements they actually have lots of
protons so they have lots of positive
charge lots of positive charge so
actually they repel each other very
effectively so it's very hard to make
heavy elements just by smacking nuclei
together turns out there's an easier way
to make heavier elements which is that
if you've got a neutron a neutral
particle and you kind of
make that stick to a nucleus so you
basically smack it into a nucleus it'll
stick and that'll add to the weight of
the nucleus now you haven't actually
changed the chemical at that point
because so chemicals are the chemical
properties of something depend on how
many protons there are on it not how
many neutrons are in it so adding a
neutron to it just changes the isotope
of the chemical it doesn't actually
change the chemical
but
neutrons can then decay through a
process called beta decay and then
neutron basically turns into a proton
and kicks out an electron and a neutrino
in the process so you sneaked a proton
in there by the back door exactly
without having to overcome these coulomb
repulsions i've been i managed to sneak
an extra particle in which then
magically turns into a proton so i've
changed the element that way so it turns
out that's actually the main way you
make these heavy elements it's just by
adding neutrons and in a supernovae
there's loads of neutrons around huge
neutron flux because there's lots of
everything around it here supernova it's
a complete mess and so you can have a
nucleus and you can just basically
bombard a whole load of neutrons into it
and then it'll end up a very heavy
isotope of whatever it started with but
then those neutrons will go bing bing
bing bing and will be to decay down into
protons so you can end up creating
heavier elements that way and that works
great you can actually you know it
decays once and that moves it one place
up the periodic table because you've
added a proton effectively and then it
decays again and so you can kind of walk
your way up the periodic table that way
the problem is that sooner or later in
that process you'll reach a stable
isotope one which will just stay there
forever so it'll decay for a while and
then it'll stick
and that means that anything kind of
further upstream from that nucleus you
can't make any more because it you've
got stuck at that point where um it's
actually it's you know everything's
decayed as far as it's going to and
nothing else is going to happen to it
after that so what i've just described
is a thing called the r process or
standing for rapid because you added a
whole bunch of neutrons very rapidly now
there are other chemicals that exist in
the universe that are kind of blocked by
this process that they wouldn't actually
form from this process and the only way
you can make those is through this thing
called the s process which is the slow
process which is that you add a neutron
you wait for a decay it turns into a
proton that changes it and then you add
another neutron and you wait for it
decay and it turns into the next element
up and that way you you don't have this
kind of blocking effect because you can
always just add another neutron and then
it'll decay and so on so through that
process you can get to a whole other set
of elements
through this thing called the s process
that don't get made through the r
process but you can you know there are
other decay chains that will get you to
these s process elements but in a
supernova everything happens very
quickly right because you've got this
massive neutron flux and then it's all
over in you know hours
so you only get one go to add or unique
exactly and these decays if you do this
s process you know you add you add a
neutron sometimes these decays can take
weeks months years
thousands of years and so actually
you're never gonna that s process is
never going to work in a supernova
because you've added one and by the time
it's decayed to the next thing along
the whole supernova is over and so
you're not going to add any more
neutrons and so things which you made
through this s process can't be made in
supernovae so we have to look somewhere
else where there is this process where
you can add neutrons to things but over
a much longer period of time tens years
hundreds of years thousands of years
rather than
all in one go and it turns out that in
the late stages of some stars lives they
actually produce quite a lot of free
neutrons some of the late stage burning
things so when you're burning carbon
into heavier elements and so you
actually liberate quite a few neutrons
along the way and so there are three
neutrons over the hundreds of thousands
of years that the star is going through
this phase of its lifetime kind of
bibling around within the star which
means that you can actually then over
time add neutrons through this s process
these elements here that i was talking
about before barium lanthanum cerium
they're only made through this s process
and that means that the only way they
can possibly be made
is that there was probably from
previous generations of stars there was
a fairly heavy element in the uh in the
star like iron or something like that
which then had
later in the lifetime of the star
had these this sort of free neutron flux
bumping into it over tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of years which
would through this s process turning
into one of these heavier elements like
barium it's quite interesting that
whenever you you know whenever you get
some barium you know pretty much how
that has to perform then it's actually
quite a long story this is a rod of
barium we've gotten here that there must
have been a first generation of stars
that went supernovae throughout lots of
heavy elements
that were produced through this art
process but that wouldn't have made the
barium then some of those heavy elements
were then
incorporated into a later generation of
stars later in the lifetime of that
particular star there was a strong
neutron flux within the star which would
then through this s process get it up to
these these heavy elements like barium
and lanthanum quite a journey some of
those atoms have been on it really is
and i you know it's kind of astounding
that just by sort of understanding the
nuclear physics and how these various
chemical elements get made you can
actually trace you know when you've got
one of these elements you can actually
look at it and say well i know how this
must have formed and it's quite as you
say it's a kind of long and involved
story in some of these elements we
should be able to file a little bit of
the barium onto this foil
oh i can see little bits coming off
actually they're very very small